>> Laura: IT'S FRIDAY!
IT MEANS IT'S TIME FOR "FRIDAY
FOLLIES!"
FOR THAT, WE TURN TO RAYMOND
ARROYO.
ALL RIGHT, RAYMOND, IT'S HARD
TO.
[INDISCERNIBLE]
SUPER HEROES.
I UNDERSTAND.
>> IT'S A BIRD.
IT'S A PLANE.
IT'S A CANCELLATION, LAURA.
THAT GIRL, THIS $100 MILLION
FILM EPIC, IT WAS SCRAPPED BY
WARNER BROTHERS THIS WEEK.
THE FILM HAD MICHAEL KEATON
RETURNING AS A CREEPY CAPED
CRUSADER.
THE MOVIE WAS CANNED FOLLOWING
TEST SCREENINGS.
IT WAS SOMETHING, I CAN
IMAGINE.
>> Laura: WHO NEEDS TEST
SCREENINGS?
THE TRAILER HAS, WHAT?
YOU LOOKED AT IT, IT HAD BAT
BOMB WRITTEN ALL OVER IT.
>> WELL, MATTHEW, WHO HOSTS
SPOTIFY'S "THE TOWN PODCAST"
SPOKE TO SOMEONE WHO ATTENDED
THIS BAT GIRL SCREENING.
IT WASN'T RECEIVED WELL.
>> HE SAID THAT AFTER THE
SCREENING, THE EXECUTIVES,
WALTER OF D.C. AND SOME OF THE
OTHERS THERE, ASKED THE
AUDIENCE, YOU KNOW, DID THIS
FEEL BIG?
AND THE CONSENSUS WAS
ABSOLUTELY NOT.
HE SAID IT PLAYED LIKE A TV
PILOT.
>> THEY THREW MILLIONS AND
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS, WARNER
BROTHERS DID, AT THIS.
IT WAS ORIGINALLY KIND OF A
SMALL MOVIE.
THEY THREW $100 MILLION, AND
WHEN THEY SCREENED IT, IT WAS
SO FLAT, THEY DECIDED TO TAKE
THE TAX WRITEOFF.
IT'S NOT EVEN BEING SHOWN ON
HBO MAX.
NOTHING!
NO COVERAGE.
THEY'RE BURYING IT.
>> Laura: I DON'T KNOW
ANYTHING ABOUT THIS.
IF I WERE TO GUESS, I WOULD
GUESS THAT THE LEAD WAS FLAT.
>> WELL, MAYBE.
WHO KNOWS?
WE NEVER GET TO SEE IT.
BUT HERE IS THE INTERESTING
THING --
>> Laura: SHE'S NOT EVEN IN
THE PROMO THERE.
>> YOU BARELY SEE HER THERE
32% OF A NEW POLL, 32% OF
MARVEL COMIC FANS THINK
THEY'RE GETTING A LITTLE TIRED
OF SO MANY SUPER HERO MOVIES.
>> Laura: OH!
THE CASH COW!
>> AND THINGS ARE SO UNSTABLE
AT D.C. FOR THE SUPER HEROES,
JASON MA MOA, AQUAMAN,
APPARENTLY STARTED A SIDE
HUSTLE AS A FLIGHT ATTENDANT.
HE'S NO LONGER PLUNGING INTO
WATER.
HE'S GIVING IT OUT.
>> HE'S DOING SUCH A GREAT
JOB.
>> Laura: NOT A BIG FAN OF
MAN BUNS BUT I'LL MAKE AN
EXCEPTION FOR HIM.
HE'S CUTE!
SO DOES SAM, BY THE WAY, SHE
JUST SAID.
HE'S CUTE.
>> EXTRA WATER IN AISLE --
>> Laura: DIDN'T YOU JUST
HAVE A WATER?
I'D LIKE ANOTHER ONE!
>> SUPER HEROES AREN'T THE
ONLY ONE UNDER WATER, LAURA.
WE'VE BEEN REPORTING FOR WEEKS
THE DANGEROUS SIDE OF THEME
PARKS FROM RIOTS TO BRAWLS,
FAMILY COME-APARTS.
THIS WEEK AT DISNEY WORLD,
IT'S NOT ONLY A SMALL WORLD
BUT A TORTUROUS ONE.
NOT ONLY DID THE RIDE KNOWN AS
THE HAPPIEST CRUISE THAT EVER
SAILED TRAPPED VISITORS IN
THEIR BOATS FOR OVER AN HOUR
BUT ONE OF THEM STARTED TO
SINK!
YOU KNOW, LAURA, THIS
ATTRACTION WAS BUILT IN THE
1964 WORLD'S FAIR.
IT WAS PROBABLY BUILT WHEN THE
BMI WAS A LITTLE BIT LOWER
THAN IT IS TODAY.
>> Laura: OH, THAT'S WHY
THEY HAVE TO MAKE THE EXTRA
WIDE COFFINS NOW FOR PEOPLE,
RIGHT?
APPARENTLY -- NO ONE WAS HURT,
>> NO ONE WAS HURT.
>> Laura: AS IT WAS SLOWLY
SUBMERGING ITSELF, APPARENTLY
THE MUSIC KEPT GOING, SO
THAT'S A NICE TOUCH.
>> BUT THAT'S THE MOST
TORTUROUS PART OF ALL TO HAVE
TO SIT THERE AND LISTEN TO
THAT SONG FOR OVER AN HOUR.
JUST IMAGINE THAT.
THESE PEOPLE SHOULD GET FREE
PASSES, LAURA.
>> Laura: REMEMBER WHEN I
GOT STUCK ON "IT'S A SMALL
WORLD" AND I DIDN'T GET OFF
FOR 1 1/2 HOURS?
THAT MUSIC, I COULDN'T GET IT
OUT OF MY HEAD.
AND ALL THE PUPPETS.
IT WAS A MICRO AND
MACROREGRESSION.
DEMOCRATS HAVE SO DESPERATE
FOR SOMEONE TO RESCUE THEM
FROM BIDEN THAT BILL CRYSTAL
ARE PUSHING JOHN LEGEND TO RUN
FOR PRESIDENT.
OH, THIS IS GOOD.
>> EVEN OLD POLITICAL HANDS
LIKE DAVID AXLEROD SEEM DRAWN
TO THIS POSSIBILITY OF LEGEND
AS POLITICAL MESSIAH.
HE APPEARED ON AXLEROD'S
PODCAST AND WAS ASKED ABOUT
HIS FRIENDSHIP WITH KANYE
WEST.
>> OH, YOU KNOW, WE ARE NOT
FRIENDS AS MUCH AS WE USED TO
BE.
HONESTLY I THINK BECAUSE WE
PUBLICLY DISAGREED ON HIS
RUNNING FOR OFFICE AND
SUPPORTING TRUMP.
I THINK IT BECAME TOO MUCH FOR
US TO SUSTAIN OUR FRIENDSHIP
HONESTLY.
>> Laura: SO HE'S THE MOST
-- I MEAN, INTOLERANT PERSON
OUT THERE.
THIS IS THE TYPICAL LIBERAL.
THEY CLAIM TO BE SO TOLERANT
AND OPEN.
AREN'T WE WOKE?
AREN'T WE -- IN THE END,
THEY'RE SNOBS.
IF YOU DON'T AGREE WITH THEM,
THEY WANT NO PART OF YOU.
>> I DON'T LIKE THE IDEA YOU
END FRIENDSHIPS OVER POLITICAL
DIFFERENCES.
THAT'S NOT THE WAY AMERICA
WORKS, AND CERTAINLY NOT A
LEADER, BUT YOU KNOW, THE
GREATEST OBJECT STACKLE TO
LEGEND EVER BEING -- OBSTACLE
TO LEGEND EVER BEING PRESIDENT
OR PURSUING POLITICS COULD BE
DESCRIBED IN TWO WORDS,
CRISTIE TEAGAN.
CAN YOU IMAGINE THIS WOMAN AS
FIRST LADY?
>> I THINK IT'S POSSIBLE TO BE
REALLY ANGRY ALL THE TIME.
>> IF THERE WAS ONE WORD YOU
WOULD HELP PARTICULARLY WOMEN
USE MORE FREQUENTLY, WHAT
WOULD THAT ONE WORD BE?
>> [BLEEP] YOU.
>> Laura: FIRST OF ALL,
SHE'S HAVING A BABY, WHICH IS
AWESOME, AND SHE HAD SOME
STRUGGLES WITH THAT, SO THAT'S
FANTASTIC.
THE DESPERATION ON THE PART OF
DEMOCRATS IS SO PALPABLE IN
GOING THERE.
>> WELL, AND THEY'VE BEEN
TRYING TO REHABILITATE CRISTIE
TEAGAN FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS
SINCE SHE TOLD THAT TEENAGER
"GO KILL YOURSELF."
AGAIN, WHEN YOU DISAGREE WITH
SOMEBODY, WISHING THEM DEATH
OR ENDING FRIENDSHIPS --
>> Laura: SHE APOLOGIZED FOR
THAT.
>> PROBABLY NOT THE RIGHT WAY
TO GO.
SHE DID APOLOGIZE BUT I JUST
DON'T KNOW IF THIS HAS
POLITICAL LEGS.
I THINK IT'S GOT AS MUCH FLOAT
TO IT AS ONE OF THE SMALL
WORLD BOATS.
>> Laura: A LEGEND IN THEIR
OWN MIND.
>> LEGENDS IN THEIR OWN MINDS.
>> Laura: RAYMO